hey y'all uh nice to meet you I wish I
had a Cheesy title up here for you all
but I was working on limited time so
it's exactly what it says it is we're
gonna be focusing on building
observability tools for uh to be able to
be able to better understand how machine
learning models function and when they
don't function so let's talk a little
bit about me I'm Alicia I'm a uh I kind
of go between the titles of data
engineer machine learning engineer and
the Machine learning platform and in
this talk I'm really focusing on like
sort of data aspects so we're going with
that
um I'm focusing on the machine learning
feature store I'll explain a little bit
more about that in a moment if you don't
know what a feature store is I'm based
in Amsterdam in the Netherlands you can
probably tell from my accent that I'm
not Dutch I wish I was that'd be cool
but I'm from the US so one other thing
you should know about me is I tend to
like to walk and I know I'm not supposed
to so I've got this little bear here for
all the remote presenters they can hang
out and see the bear when I like am gone
from this so anyway let's talk about
observability
um why do we care about it most people
don't at least not to start what they
want to do is solve hard problems and
usually like machine learning is one of
those tools you use to solve the problem
you work on it you figure out the right
parameters the right type model and you
finally want to release it into the
world and it totally bombs why does it
bomb that's the stuff I care about I
want to know when the model has issues
that's the most fun thing for me and uh
there's a couple ways to deal with when
a model has issues one obvious and
really important aspect I mean slow down
is I think I'm getting too excited about
the whole model of having problem thing
um you want to introduce alerting and
monitoring because if the model has a
problem if for example it's just not
responding if there's a model outage you
want to know that fast you want to have
a monitor in place that will let you
know that hey this you know we're not
getting any hits at this endpoint it's
not responding or that the predictions
it's giving aren't making sense so we
want to be able to catch when it's at
risk but what I'm going to talk about
today is how we know how to improve the
model how to better understand what went
wrong so we can fix it next time so
that's observability and I'm going to
take this weird uh Kickback to explain a
little bit about what machine learning
platform is because I want to present
this in the context of how we went about
building tools and one of the big
aspects is that there are multiple
players in this whole game of fixing of
developing observability so I mentioned
I work on the feature store what is a
feature store our feature store is sort
of like the membrane that sits between
the data platform and all of its
pipelines and the Machine learning
platform world we feed data pipelines
into the feature store that are
specifically designed to serve up
features they want to use them one or
more models we think of it as a
marketplace where the feature store is
the broker that is managing the sharing
of data between the people providing it
and the people pulling data from it so
that we can maintain some metadata
around what the features are and be able
to track various aspects about it we
also have a core like basically making
sure that we're allocating the right
computational resources to be able to
serve a model making sure that you know
we have allocated the right amount of
gpus CPUs memory that sort of thing and
on top of it pipelines that might be a
little bit less clear it's how our data
scientists designed the training and
start serving of models I'm actually
going to go into that a little bit more
model registry is where we save our
models alongside metadata and be able to
pull them and it's sort of like it's
sort of like our like get repository for
models I'm trying to think of how to
explain that in case people here don't
do machine learning and then also we
serve models at endpoints to be able to
you know handle uh online prediction so
that's our online inference system our
Focus today is going to be on the
feature store pipelines in online
inference because these are the three
different parts of our platform that
we're deeply involved in surfability I
kind of like to think of it as you know
where it's sort of like collaborators in
this fight against model breakage and
um on the other side of our you know
three players we have our three big
challenges which I like to think of as
our boss fights
um I have to disclaim that we are in
Prototype phase so we have we have built
intend prototypes for uh for this but we
are not necessarily these are not
necessarily things are going to be like
build so I'm going to I can mention
along the way what we used but like if
you're like how did this work in
production I can tell you well our build
is happening so we'll find out maybe
I'll give a talk on how this all sucked
but
for now we're gonna we've been doing
prototyping and phase uh testing phases
and I can share with you a lot of the
designs we've been working on our first
boss by this is my favorite because it's
one I worked on uh data quality issues
when your data is just wrong when maybe
it just decided not to show up that day
so you need fresh data and it isn't
there or it showed up but it has random
nulls in it or uh data values that you
know aren't accurate maybe it's passing
in like weird like the wrong type
there's a lot of different things that
can happen here but essentially the data
is not accurate and it's not accurate in
the way that we as data Engineers can
catch
uh we focus on the feature store in this
one because after all the feature store
is the one working between the data
pipelines that are feeding it in and the
consumers that are taking data out so we
chose this part of the platform it's the
one that made a lot of sense to be where
we validate where we Define what the
validations look like and we actually
validate the data that's coming in I I
picked a robot because I didn't want to
make one that looked like myself and
like robot I don't know how do you
visualize a feature store as a character
let me know if you have better ideas
um one of the most simple things we
actually did was we actually needed to
find a way to define what validations
looked like and this isn't python which
is actually weirdly the point because we
realized that we needed to uh validate
and you know run these validations uh
using different libraries depending on
what our performance requirements were
but we also didn't want to be be the
people in charge of defining what valid
data was people who best know what like
data what the data should look like are
the people who are providing it the
people who designed the features so we
wanted to give the feature owners a way
to be able to Define their data quality
like metrics or sorry their data file
their data quality rules and the way
that we could under the hood implement
it and also be able to like raise this
metadata through various parts of our
like for example our data catalog for
other people we will see and easily
understand that's another thing like
performant code isn't necessarily like
easily understandable code so
um we like it's really valuable to be
able to have this easy way for people to
look at the data so um I I will point
out that actually we did a validate
where we did run uh validations using a
couple different libraries to test
implementations so including like red
expectations and the one that we
actually ended up using was y logs
um it can go into that probably at the
end I want to make sure we have time to
cover everything uh the other thing that
we needed to do is make sure we actually
like people could actually see whether
the data matched those rules because
it's one thing to set these rules it's
another thing to know hey is this
feature actually meeting its quality
standards so for this we had to address
a couple of different use cases as an
engineer on the platform I need to know
if there's something going wrong on our
end so for example if an entire set of
features from the same table are just
like not showing up is that an issue
with a pipeline that's being fed in is
there something going on with our
feature server that's not accepting data
people who are wanting to use a feature
might want to know whether or not that
feature is valid before making the
decision that way if you have multiple
variations of the same feature to find
like they can make a bit make the
decision that's right for them on what
the most valid version of that data is
the most valid version of that feature
is ideally you don't have the case where
you have multiple people defining the
same feature but this is a potential
thing that could arise where for example
one feature is based on outdated data
you make it a new feature using the new
like improved pipeline uh one other
thing uh that we need to consider is the
people who are providing the data
recognize the feature has is invalid and
they recognize what is going on to be
able to debug what's going on they need
to know what rule specifically failed
and be able to understand like okay at
what point in time did this rule start
failing at what point did we start
getting negative values for like you
know for sales or something like that
oh because I really wanted to show you
we did actually build it all to show you
the ugliest graph ever because in order
to make enough errors we had to randomly
throw in a bajillion of them
um so we uh this is an example of just
like being able to track errors over
time if it was real data and not
randomly generated you should be able to
see degradation as the errors where a
visualized seen debugged and addressed I
also want to mention the gauges because
you might have the case where you know
you're having noisy data with potential
errors and you might have thresholds for
when you want to be alerted so instead
of you know not just having the
historical point of view but knowing
like okay like what percentage of this
incoming data is is showing errors at
this point in time
that's all I gotta say about that I
think how are we doing okay cool so
let me click
it's not clicking let's try that again
all right so the other thing we need to
address is again volume and the fact
that there's this big trade-off between
data freshness and valid data some use
cases need to have fresh data available
like for example for online use cases
and there are certain types of
validations when we talk to our users
they're like well you know obviously it
matters if this data is going to break
the you know the model's code like if
it's just like if someone flipped up
whether it's a string or an integer and
that breaks our code that's not going to
work but if it's a like an anomalous
value I don't care unless it hits that
certain like threshold of like
percentage of incoming valid data or
invalid data so at that case they
actually need the most fresh data in
order to be able to give the best
possible prediction for
um you know for the online use case so
we had ended up breaking this down so
that you could see not just the amount
of incoming records and written records
for a given feature or feature set but
also the validation errors and
specifically ones that hit that highest
severity level that would cause the
record to not be written to the online
store so
um in this case it kind of breaks down
the validation rules where like okay
there's something going on and we need
to like we need to track the history of
this to see if there's you know if if
it's the occasional null versus like a
lot of nulls affecting this features
validity versus like you know an error
that would cause like a fatal issue with
the served model I feel like I said that
weird so I'm not going to be surprised
someone asked me a question about that
in a moment but anyway that that's the
general issues recognizing that
validations of different levels of
severity and we put them all at highest
severity by default but the feature
providers sometimes will need to
recognize like okay this is something
one keep track of but isn't necessarily
as severe as other issues
all right
I want to get on to our next boss fight
though which is something that I I
actually have no idea of people
um know about either data drift or why
on Earth or sea otters here
um so data drift is the situation where
the distribution of data is changed so
for example if you've trained your data
and then when you and when you release
it you realize that the Imp that the
data that you've trained on is different
has a different distribution than the
incoming data that you're seeing in
production or that is changing over time
you know potential you know for our
outside reasons
for sea otters they deal with drift in
Water by holding hands in order to make
sure they stay close together but
unfortunately we don't really have that
option as machine learning engineers
all right so instead what we do is
um we I mentioned earlier pipelines and
I promise to explain a little bit more
the concept of pipelines is essentially
an API for data scientists to be able to
define the machine learning training and
um I said product training production so
but really here it's machine learning
training steps and also prediction batch
prediction in production steps uh using
a simple API
and the way we will use it here is we
introduce new steps where they can
snapshot distributions in order to
monitor them
I think I need a visual to make this
make a little bit more sense so
essentially they Define their data
ingestion step any additional
post-processing they need to do after
ingesting the data and then running you
know training their model and same thing
for the production pipeline they Define
you know the data ingestion feature
process post-processing and the batch
prediction steps and then like the
training one both of these are similar
AP you know they're the same API but you
can run it locally for you know
experimentation or for the production
pipeline you can transfer that API to a
an airflow dag that will run it on a
regular basis
so so how do we introduce drift
monitoring to this we basically add in
an additional step where you can add you
know it's data ingest and snapshot data
feature processing snapshot feature
distribution training snapshot the label
distribution when you introduce this the
production pipeline the reason it's
valuable to mention the airflow deck is
when you you can run this and then when
you push it as a dag it will actually
run those steps whenever you run the DAC
and then we save those snapshot
distributions what do we do with the
snapshots so these snapshots again we
use y logs in this prototype and Y logs
provides like a statistical profile
which is which provides insight into
distribution in different statistical
values like you know the Min mean like
most frequent values that sort of thing
but in a much more condensed form and
what we can do is when that snapshot is
made uh data scientists have well before
even the snapshots made data scientists
can customize the report template for
how they want to visualize that profile
so this is an example of like someone
has made a profile template where they
want to be able to see the distribution
and general count of different the
distribution total count and various
like values about this profile like for
example how many missing values do they
have for a given feature what's the
general mean that sort of thing and um
and then whenever the dag is run or
whenever you run the training pipeline
the cement profile is made then it's
added to it's combined with this data
report and generated uh into an HTML
file that's saved in the model registry
so that someone can go to the model
registry go to that model and see okay
here's the snapshot that we got in the
last run you know here's the report I've
customized to be able to see the
different statistical qualities that I
care about this is really helpful if for
example you want to do segmentation
which might be specific to your your
specific set of data one example use
case might be if you want to look at you
know overall statistics for sales but
then you want to be able to break it
down and track distributions per country
you could do that with a report like
this because you can customize the exact
types of statistical analyzes you see so
and I think that
um yeah so that was why I lost in the
data report template in actual like
saving them registry we prototyped that
part with our common ml model registry
mentioning set because people keep
asking me and I feel like it's valuable
um so boss fight three so you bring your
model home and you know you want it to
behave in specific ways but you really
don't know what it's going to do this is
my cat and this is basically what he
gets up to all the time
um so uh but with models you actually
have a little bit more hope of
understanding what they are doing
um so when our model isn't working as
expected how can we dig into what went
wrong or see that it went wrong
um for this we instrument our online
endpoint
so this is really helpful be well this
is actually the main way that we are you
know we're already serving our model at
this endpoint so we can go ahead and
instrument it to track various
properties about the model that can help
us better understand what it's being
exposed to and how it's acting
um oh
god
um so
um all right so we're currently
evaluating these we're looking at a
couple different solutions but these
were
um you know talking to a team that's
current doing the evaluations these are
things that we're caring about the most
at the moment first we need to know that
the model is available
um I mentioned that earlier but I think
a good uh a metaphor for this is one
that uh my teammate gave me is this like
concept of like with drift you know that
like ice cream sales will change from
Summer to winter but like what we really
care about is like making sure that the
ice cream truck didn't break down so if
the model is out then like that takes
out everything else we know that with
online inference one of our big things
is we need to make sure we have low
latency and responses so we need to know
that whatever solution we're however
we're instrumenting the endpoint it
shouldn't introduce additional latency
possible if we should like introduces
like a side card solution
one other situation that we need to
handle is anomalous inputs I think I
alluded to this maybe didn't explicitly
say this earlier but with the feature
store we need to consider whether we're
well I did mention this that sometimes
we need to block records if they're just
if they're uh to you know if they're
erroneous in a destructive way we can't
really address this in the same way with
an online model because we get a request
and what the data we get is what we got
so we need to be able to handle the
imperfect data but we also want to know
that we got like invalid data because we
you know if the model is giving out
weird response we need to know okay this
is a problem with the the data so in the
request and maybe that implies an issue
with whatever
software is sending that request to us
so being able to track that is important
and of course like same thing with batch
prediction We Still In online inference
we also care about tracking changes in
you know data in label distributions
over time
all right
let me go quick to obviously I've been
talking a lot about observability in
normal models my normal I mean like the
models that were not generative AI that
did not involve prompts that did not
involve needing to think about whether
or not the user was engaging with the
model and their how much they value
interacting with it without them
worrying about the model like
hallucinating very like confident
sounding answers but like actually now
we kind of have to so that's kind of fun
um I don't like parrots whenever I see
the Slime but
um okay so what are the things we need
to think about I actually
started writing a lot of like here's
different methods and then like this
this field changes every day so I think
it's actually better to step back and
focus on the basics so with data quality
are we providing the right information
for the model to accomplish the task one
thing that's really interesting is the
concept of like model degeneracy with
generative AI if you're giving like
talking to a few people about this about
like the fact that if you make the
prompts too long and the model isn't
used to that or the model is expecting a
specific structure
um and it's and so if it doesn't get the
structure expects or the prompt is too
long it will behave in ways you don't
expect so this is Broad things you know
different examples of whether or not the
data is matching the expected training
uh data format so this might be
something that like I can't solve
hallucinations but I can when tracking
incoming data that's going to be fed to
gender of AI model check and make sure
that it's actually matching the expected
format data drift this is kind of
changing as models are starting to get
access to up-to-date databases
um but just if your answers you have
require needing something needing to
know something about the currency of the
world doesn't actually have the ability
to get that
um prediction performance this is
another thing that is sort of like an
interesting ongoing situation we can we
look at
all right we look at things like okay
like what are how is the search compared
to you know our traditional search or
how summarization compared to our other
summarization approaches but one thing
that we have to take into account is
this new focus on user uh engagement
which is more along the lines of like
you know what is the what how do we
categor qualify the uh quality of an
ongoing conversation between a user and
the bot
um I'm low on time so I'm going to move
ahead to takeaways the takeaways are I
mentioned three different parts of the
of the platform we work together to make
sure that we have a consistent interface
for our users to be able to engage with
the different observability tools we
also made it we try to focus a lot on
things like picking the same libraries
for our prototypes that's why I'm
mentioning why logs a lot then it being
our best fit for the overall
components we also focus a lot on data
yeah data scientists people own the
process and make it easy for them to
understand how to do it and there's all
the people that were involved and I'm
now available for questions thank you
for doing a great job on time monitoring
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Alicia Barger for that Vivid
lecture I think we can all go more
energetic into coffee break but first we
have some questions you can also type in
your questions via slido I will read
them out now
who are usually feature owners okay
feature owners
Um this can be a couple different things
so we have at Shopify we have data
developers analytic engineers and data
scientists analytic Engineers sort of
sit in between the two where they design
tables that are meant to capture the
underlying quality of a feature
um so I I'm sure when we have an
analytic engineer they'll be like no
that's not right but that's how I
understand them to be so the feature
owners are typically data scientists
working with data Engineers or analytic
Engineers to you know register their
pipeline to the feature store
so could a Star Wars style Droid
be one of the feature owners of Star
Wars uh Droid like a bartender Droid
um
I mean you know if they Define their
feature and they can write it up in the
feature store they might not be the best
maintainers they might be especially if
it's a bartender robot that might be
busy doing other things
um typically these are internal uh
feature producers and consumers I should
clarify that next question is which tool
platform are you using for the drift
report
okay so the drift report so the
statistical profile is generated using
the Y logs Library which is an open
source Library provided by y Labs the
report template is
um is being pro like the actual ability
to host it actually I think y log
provides the ability to make the
generate the report as well it's the
hosting and the combination with the
template that is provided by Common ml's
model registry
next question is how do you handle the
problem of having too many dashboards
alerts Etc which all kind of seemed
relevant to implement but are too many
to keep track of that's totally fair so
um and I'm glad that was mentioned
because one thing I didn't mention is
that
um that that remember that data quality
monitoring dashboard with bajillions of
errors that was actually made in a
grafana which we host internally as our
tool observe and we've tried to focus as
many of our monitoring reports there as
possible the snapshot temp report
template is in the model registry
because that is where we felt like it
made sense but if people felt like that
was too many dashboards they'd probably
move in to observe grafana provides a
lot of customizability around the
alerting so that you can alert you can
choose to alert based on like strict
rules like oh there's an error in your
data or you can provide like specific
slos and that you like we've decided to
let the data like the feature owners or
model owners customize that but that's
that's been our approach to handling the
noise so Focus everything in one place
and give them ownership so if it's too
much for them it's irrelevant they they
know what it is and can modify it as
need be
then who really checks the dashboards
PMS data scientists engineers or who
okay
it probably matters which dashboard
we're talking about I think that the
ones that are going to be like around
the drift distribution in Mobile
performance are going to be primarily
the model owners
um sometimes it will be people from my
team as well because we want to make
sure like for example if all the models
are out that's probably our fault right
so we or sometimes we also help people
understand what went on with their model
to make sure it's not an infrastructural
issue for the feature dashboards that
might be people considering using that
feature you know so if they're like
evaluing what features to add to test in
their model they might be looking at
that as well as people who are actively
using it trying to figure out what went
wrong with their model or people who who
are like received an alert because they
own it the owners the people who are in
charge of fixing it are usually the
people that we hope you know that we
have being alerted so for the data
quality that would be us because I'm in
the feature store and we need to know
that but also the people who own that
data pipeline
are all tools costume Solutions are our
open source tools are used
um right now we we did this full
prototype with with the exception of
comet ml those were all we've been using
open source we are currently evaluating
more stuff in Google Cloud which is our
cloud provider so like whether or not to
use different ASP tooling from vertex AI
but that's where I was saying I mean the
Prototype phase so like everything that
you've seen thus far has been with the
exception of common ml has been open
source I can't say in the build phase
what it will look like
okay last question before coffee break I
mentioned airflow deck do you use it
only to check the task progress or
status
we use airflow to schedule like batch
prediction jobs as well as like you know
potential like batch dumps uh you know
the feature store accepts like batch
produced data as well uh we also run it
like it's sort of a general it's
shopify's General scheduling
infrastructure so anything that needs to
be on the schedule we use airflow is
that did that answer your question
correctly okay okay thank you for your
presentation for answering to all these
questions to you all have a nice coffee
break again thank you thanks for coming